It's okay.
>> Let me just cry.
Did you cry like that to the young girl?
The young Palestinian girl. They were
they were child who was shot nearly 306
times. 60 times. Did you shed a tear for
that? Mr. Christian, we love all our
enemies. Huh?
I'm so happy to be able to talk to you
today and mashallah my brother our Ali
Hammuda is doing a great job. Work
forever is a very very uh beautiful
cause because the reward of what you
give is not just at the moment of giving
but rather it is prolonged for a very
very long time and it lasts for as long
as that work continues to generate to
generate some form of benefit. So I
highly recommend walk forever as an
ambassador of Abdullah Aid. I know the
the uh partnership that we have is
amazing and uh not many people
understand the concept of wak yet the
reward is far greater through the wak.
So inshallah if you can support work
forever uh it will be really really
amazing and very very rewarding.
Asalam alalaykum brothers and sisters.
Dear friends, um I want to do a video
about this just to show the hypocrisy,
the double standards of these Christian
apologetics. Bro, you cannot make this
up. The greatest there's no greater hate
than Christian love. That's that's
period. There is no greater hate than
Christian love. I'm in Dawa in in
Leicester Square and um we there's one
heck that comes there every single week,
bro. She does double shift from uh speak
comes in headquarters. Yeah. I go I love
Jesus. I sh I love Jesus. She gets
angry. But how could you how could you
get angry when someone says I love
Jesus? This is shows you their hate for
Islam is greater than their love for
Christianity and justice. Greater. And
I'm going to prove it out. Here's a
video of no logic. The triangle square
guy. Yes. The triangle can be a square
and square can be triangle. Yes. Okay.
Just watch this guy. Just watch. This is
this is his reaction to Charlie Kirk's
death. Look how look how fake this
person is, bro. It talks about
Christianity as love and this that and I
said the same thing to him when I
confronted him in speaker's corner.
Okay. I said we as Muslims are closer to
you yet you ally yourself with a Zionist
Zionist Jews. Yes. Which say that your
God is burning in feces my friend.
Feces. Feces. Charlie Ker.
Charlie Kerb was even talking about
slavery being okay. Yes. And you as a
black man check this. Just check this
out. Let's watch for our self.
>> Said to him, "Well done, good and
faithful servant. You have been faithful
over a little. I will set you over over
much.
Enter into man.
It's okay.
I love you.
>> Let me just
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I still got to do
this.
>> Show enough.
You know, it's it's weird because it's
uh this is beautiful. You know,
Philippians 1:21, y'all. It could be any
of us.
It happened to Christ first. It happened
to the apostles. It happened to the
prophets. It happens to believers. It's
happening to Christians right now as we
speak. This is just a small example.
This is just a small example. Christians
are being martyed all over the place in
Nigeria and China. All over the place,
man.
Of course, there's Christians being
persuaded by I'm sure I'm sure there it
happens. I'm sure there's Hindus. I'm
sure there's Jews. I'm sure there's
Muslims. If we look at over majority
Muslims have been massacred in the 20
years, I'm not saying one is over the
other. The the the thing I'm trying to
put my mind across is the following. Did
you cry like that to the young girl, the
young Palestinian girl? They were they
were child that they deeming a woman who
were who was shot nearly 306 times. 60
times. Did you shed a tear for that, Mr.
Christian? We love all our enemies. Huh?
Now, I'm not saying you can't be upset
what happened to Charlie Kirk. I'll be
honest with you. I don't mourn his
death. Neither do I condone it. Yes.
someone who was genocidal, who was
progenocidal. I don't wish that on
anybody because number one, he's not our
teacher. Charlie Kirk is not our
teacher. Islam, the Quran, is our
teacher. Nowhere in Islam does it tell
us yes to support anyone. If I'm telling
you if that was me, Muhammad Hijam or
anyone close to me that was pro genocide
towards the Christian population,
towards the Jewish population, innocent
population, Hindu population, I don't
care. Seek population. Let me tell you
something. Even if he was a Muslim, let
me tell you something. Yeah. I would not
shed a tear. I would not shed a tear.
I'll be upset the way that they've been
killed, etc. However, I'll be saying I'm
so sorry. with all due respect. Allah
says in the Quran, speak the truth even
if it's against yourself or your kin. So
I'm not going to cry over a Muslim who
was pro- genocide towards argument sake.
Let it was there was a Muslim nation
that was massacring innocent men, women
and children, Christians and Jews that
were being massacred at the hands of a
Muslim empire that was representing
Islam. I would have condemned them till
the day I die. And I would condemn that
individual who was pro that pro that.
and was seeing innocent Christian girls
getting massacred and was doing what?
Yeah. Being starved, saying there's no
starvation
and you're here, you know, and you want
us to buy your fake. You're fake. Deep
down your fame because if you was
consistent, you would care about the
life of every anyone else. When I saw
the stabbing of that Ukrainian woman who
would move to America to run from what's
going on in Russia, I mean uh Russia's
the war between Russia and Ukraine. It
hurt me. I was bothered. That was a
Christian woman. And I was so
angry to see an innocent woman walking
about her business sat there get stabbed
in the neck. Nobody helps her. Yes. And
it's not a black making as old. No. I
believe even if there was a wife,
whoever was there like they didn't know,
they didn't know what was going on.
Nobody saw the blood. And she is there
horrified looking not knowing what's
going on. That was hurtful. That was
painful. Yes. Not because Oh.
Not that she was a Muslim. Doesn't
matter. She's a human being. Human
being. So I know no logic you're
watching this. You shameless man. You
fake. You are fake. You're not real.
When was the last time you shed a tear
for the Palestinians in the garden? You
rather support what? Do you speak
against it? You do videos with Apus, the
bastard who was there saying there is no
genocide. They deserve what's happening
to them. And this is Christian love.
Yeah. This is Christian love. So don't
come to me with that fake tears, man.
Yeah, it's fake because you're not
consistent. We are morally consistent.
You guys are strategically consistent.
You don't call out the government. You
don't come here and condemn what Israel
is doing or speak out against it or shed
one tear for the thousands of innocent
and little children being blown into
pieces, man. So, shame on you. Shame on
you. Shame on you. And I know you're
watching this and I know my words are
hitting your heart and I know it is and
let it hit yours ap all of you cowards.
You know why? Cuz your hate to Islam is
greater than your love for mercy and
justice to speak out against evil
wherever it is. We are consistent. If
it's done to a Christian, to a Muslim,
to a Hindu, to a Jew, whomever it is for
that matter, we condemn it. So I don't
buy it. And like I said before, I've
done in my first video, my second video,
it's my third or fourth video. Let me
tell you something. Nobody who's
speaking should be attacked or killed.
Nobody. Which shows you the the the
flawed logical of freedom of speech.
Yes. Because even Trump said it's it's
this rhetoric. This rhetoric that he's
spewing that's caused Charlie Kirk to be
assassinated. I believe it was done by
Israel all day, every day. Yes. But the
point is what? The point is what? You
are not consistent. As Muslims, we are
morally consistent. Alhamdulillah, we
condemn any killing that's done to
Christians in Nigeria, wherever Muslims
been massacred, Hindus, wherever it is,
we condemn it. You guys, you only shed a
tear when it is someone like you know
like like man come on get out of here
man please I'm I don't the point is made
clearcut we are consistent and we are
not like you guys. Alhamdulillah we are
the barbarians. We are the one that
Islam teaches to kill them wherever.
Okay. Alhamdulillah, our religion
teaches us what? No, no, no, no, no.
They are not. You are not our teachers.
You apus, you little weasel. You little
weasel. Yes. God. No logic. You're no
logic, bro. No logic. And Charlie Kirk
and many like him. You're not our
teachers. That's why we don't want the
same that you promote. That's should be
done to the Gaza to be done to you.
That's why I condemned it. It should not
be done. That's what I say. Asalam
alaikum.